[Music]
hello film independent members and
welcome to this film independent
presents q a for the oscar shortlisted
documentary short film audible currently
streaming on netflix
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's not what we go through
it's how we go through it
[Music]
the reality of this life
is that we are going to face some
adversity we must examine
who we are
i'm jen wilson senior programmer with
film independent thank you to the hfpa
and vision media who hosts our
film independent presents virtual
screening room please welcome today's
guest director of audible matthew ogins
thank you
um i really really enjoyed this film
uh
a lot
it's extremely transfixing
um
it was incredibly easy to watch it's
incredibly easy world to get into
do you want to
talk about how you came to make a film
about um
a deaf high school and their football
and cheerleading squads
yeah yeah
um
you know i like to think of it as a
coming-of-age story and
less of a sports documentary
in that you know sports cheerleading are
aspects of a high schooler's life you
know for some of them you know i
actually it took me um 10 11 12 years to
actually get made um
i grew up
30 minutes away from the school my
family is still there in the dc maryland
area near maryland school for the deaf
and my best friend since i was about
seven years old was deaf and so in some
ways perhaps
unconsciously
you know i pursued this as a way to
connect with him and understand him more
um and had lots of
sorry
this isn't live right let me just get my
dog to calm down bob come on
sorry no it's not live even so
so it took like 10 11 12 years to get
made lots of stops and starts and
different partners along the way um
until i came to netflix and i really
understood the project and the
characters and the journey and
jumped in with me
you
um i was looking over
your film credits you've made a lot of
sports related films
can you just talk about for you what it
is that attracts you
to
sports subject matter yeah you know it's
funny i'm not a sports fanatic i'm not
the guy that sits
glued to my tv all day on sunday
um yelling at the television um i kind
of fell into it and then
kind of connected with it and that i
find i like the story behind the sport
right and often i find and i think it it
applies to audible that
sports is such a perfect metaphor for
life you know
even a game has a story and ups and
downs and tension it almost has that
hero's journey right especially if
you're an underdog
um but also very metaphorical and
symbolic to the ups and downs of of life
again especially in this case
um and so i don't do just do sports but
i do come back to it time to time
because i'll find just an inspiration
all powerful story that i feel like i
connect with on a human level and just
feel like i have to tell him this
probably audible more than any
any other film i've done because i stuck
with it the longest and believed in it
when perhaps um you know others along
the way didn't
when you so when you make a film like
this
do you know what your story is going to
be ahead of time or do you use and and
which kids you're going to be focusing
on or do you sort of
uh take as much footage as you can and
then find what that story is and the
editing
did you know that omari was so
going to sort of emerge as your main
character right away
yeah i mean i think it depends on the
project um as i've evolved as a
filmmaker i
try to be more
organized and plan um and even go so far
as to outline i never know what
someone's gonna say or the endings of
certain things especially for a duck you
follow that's not historical
um you know it's a great question i'm
glad it took about a dozen years to get
made because i knew i wanted to follow a
senior because i felt that that
graduating into
college or whatever you're going to do
is such a pivotal moment in any
teenager's life but especially for a
deaf teenager that's going from a let's
say a
the safety of maryland school for the
deaf and deaf community out more into
the hearing world and becoming more of
an adult is scarier
but what that meant is every single year
i had to recast because that senior
graduated
and the reason i like i'm glad it took
that long is because i thought amari's
story really
um
epitomized some of the conflicts that
at least he dealt with some of the kids
at the school and perhaps the deaf
community his
relationship with his father um you know
being born into a
a hearing family
his father leaving at a young age
um
his relationship with a gay male
cheerleader you know a jock and a
cheerleader
um
and why they have that that bond that
relationship which is teddy who may not
always be physically present in the film
but he's very felt and very much an
important character and catalyst um and
and is a main character in the film and
so the tragedy of
um of teddy
um and and the other elements i
mentioned i thought
really made
made this version of the film stronger
so i did know
you know at a certain point this was the
version we were gonna make and that's
the version i
i i brought to netflix and then
developed from there
yeah i thought that was a a particularly
remarkable thing about this film is the
acceptance that all these kids have for
each other you know
gay and straight
black and white
it was like
these kids were all particularly bonded
in a way that it didn't any of their
their differences didn't matter
um
did you how did that surprise you as
well yeah i witnessed that as well
probably less surprising in that i've
been going back there for over 10 years
so you know i i felt that very early on
in in the process of
gaining their trust and being invited
into their world right
um
but i did feel that now caveat being
i'm not there 24 7. they're still
teenagers
i'm you know i'm not there when they're
texting and you know behind closed doors
i'm sure there's still the usual teenage
stuff and bullying and arguing but i did
feel as you said jen more than i've seen
before
this
i don't know a utopia or a safety
there where you could just be anything
and perhaps that is because
they share a bond that we don't have
you know they all share this one thing
whether they're gay straight black white
however they identify
um
wherever they're from whatever the socio
economics are there's this one thing
hearing
you know um that
is a sense
that that they share
did you have a feeling that it also had
anything to do with their generation
like this generation of kids gen z
these things are a lot less of an issue
for them
sure absolutely i mean
you know
we see what you know
teachers are expressing themselves
they're exploring themselves you know
i guess depending on where you are and
what family you're in of course
um
[Music]
you're able as jalen says in the film
you know just be yourself right he
certainly has the confidence too but it
requires your community and your family
too there's other elements um
but yeah i do think you're right this
generation i spent a lot of time
developing this i didn't want to make an
observational film from my point of view
i wanted them
i'm sorry that's okay
of course give me a second
i actually usually have pretty good luck
i don't know what's going on today
full moon the other day we're jinxed
yeah now we're good um sorry you asked
me
what was i saying oh we were talking
about um the this generation of kids and
yeah yeah
i know where i was so i spent a lot of
time i wanted it to be their film and me
just being sort of a conduit or liaison
for them to tell their film so i wanted
the color palette everything to feel
teenagery right and i spent a lot of
time talking to them what do you listen
to
um
what do you watch
how do you see the world how do you
dream what's your color palette and
wanted to sort of create that
you know
and
hopefully i i hope
we captured that visually sort of like
how at least the kids in this film see
the world and dream if that makes sense
um
so
i guess sort of applying what you said
about you know that tolerance and
openness even to the way we filmed it
i loved this project and how
you bring together these these elements
of
um
um not just like right from the
beginning when the kids are at the
football game that they're losing
and
you see them sort of started to melt
down and the the coach is trying to hold
them together
it's resilience that's the word i was
thinking about
the resilience and trying to teach
children resilience um
and i was thinking about that and i was
i you know a lot of us have been trying
to
reteach ourselves resilience during
covet 19 right
um
and what what that skill set is about
and also
um
i loved
because you bring up in the beginning
of the movie right away that um amari
has a cochlear implant which is
something that's been controversial in
the deaf community
and that teddy's sort of downfall or the
the thing that
partly was involved in his suicide was
that he tried to shift into a hearing
community
and all these kids are on the brink of
leaving school
and
assimilating and i just loved all these
how terrifying that must be for them
that they watched their best friends try
to assimilate
and not succeed at that um can you talk
about that a little bit yeah i mean it's
a big it's a big
i guess i'd even say symbolic thing in
their lives i mean i have to say like
teddy's parents say in the film
it's not just one thing right there's
there's there's other elements to
what happened with teddy um and and i
it's not my place to uh say it's one
thing but that certainly exacerbated it
um
[Music]
you know teddy's mom in the film
probably says it best
um when she says
not having access to communication you
know when you're
gonna said it earlier you know you can
be anyone on that campus i think that
applies
across the board
there's a safety right
on that campus you're certainly not
going to get bullied for being deaf
so
now you you leave that that space and we
know how teenagers can be whether it's
intentional or unintentional um
and
obviously very painful in the worst way
for for teddy
but pretty painful for his friends
and community to watch had a profound
effect on them um hopefully you felt
that
as sort of a cautionary tale
in the film that let's
be a little more curious
empathetic all human beings i mean maybe
it sounds cliche but
i think it's cliche for a reason like
just be kind
try to get to know someone maybe they
can teach you something
right these kids taught me a lot
um
so omar says at the beginning that he
only listens to his cochlear implants to
listen to music
and there's a scene later on where
he's sitting around a table with his
family who's talk who's speaking and not
in sign language
and then he leaves and and you ask him
if
uh something about isolation if he feels
isolated because he's the only deaf
person
do you think
the cochlear implant is something that
he would begin to use more once he's out
of school and he's not completely
surrounded by deaf people
you know it's all happening in real time
right fair speech
it's different for everyone but he's for
him he's not hearing clear speech i mean
as he even says even with headphones on
listening to music blasting he's feeling
it right he feels music he gave me his
playlists you know the music in the film
is inspired by these kids as i said
um
but he's not hearing the lyrics of that
song so he's not going to be able to
have
full access to communication in terms of
hearing what his family is saying you
know
um
look like i said he wasn't born deaf he
got meningitis around two years old
which
that's how my best friend lost his
hearing at about the same age which is
interesting
his family doesn't know fluent sign
language they're getting there they get
better and better they're pretty good
you see it
especially his mom but even if his
family was
as fluent as he is
the fact that they are hearing and he's
deaf is going to have some kind of
separation because
you're around that kitchen table they're
not all signing with each other
you know you're at a dinner you're
you're at a family outing whatever it
may be you know sitting around the tv
normal family stuff that we may take for
granted they're all still communicating
with each other through voice and
hearing
so he's going to be left out and feel
isolated one way or the other
right and
you know going upstairs putting on
cochlear implants and listening to music
in that cocoon
you know is a way for him to
decompress maybe a way for him to avoid
i'm not his therapist but
um
i wanted to talk about the filming of
this because
uh it's particularly beautiful to look
at
and i'm not somebody that watched sports
either so i know when when
i am
um
able to watch several football game
scenes
and be immersed that i know it that's
shot
really particularly well do you want to
talk about the look yeah
well i mean that's great what you said
you know the idea is
we're going to get a sports audience
this isn't that's just a metaphor that's
the hook it's it's ideally we're
transcending sport and capturing people
that couldn't care less right
um
i uh
you know
i'm binging the second season of cheer i
didn't think i'd be into cheerleading
the show and the characters
made me interested in it you know um
and so
earlier i had said we really i wanted to
make this we wanted to make this an
audio visual immersive experience
especially since there's not a lot of
voice in the film it's mostly subtitles
and captions
um with some sporadic
voice from some hearing characters uh
through through parents right
teddy's parents and omaree's parents um
in a moment with a hearing coach that
they play against towards the end
and so
we wanted to create like this visual
film language that felt like how like
amari and the kids and jalen and lyra
see the world
and
really get in there and make it feel
again like it's not observational but
it's it's i don't know if i'm
articulating right but it's
it's really their point of view in a way
and really in there with them almost
like the character is
someone else in the room with them
that's death
you know and and the sound as well you
know really
treating sound
like a character
yeah whether it's music or sound design
but you know
our team really collaborated so it's one
soundscape and again talking to amari he
feels those bass sounds the distortions
so
our composer and our sound design team
played with that as well because we want
you to feel that
yeah
in your gut
i think um
i i really appreciated your sound design
in this because it's sort of sometimes
you were
it seemed like you
if you were focusing on amari you were
um
yours the sound was designed for his
particular viewpoint but at other times
like in the beginning of the film you
know when they're they're losing that
football game and they're in the locker
room they're so upset there's a lot like
so many loud noises people slamming
things
and it's
it's it throws you into this like
this is what hearing people hear of of
deaf people like they don't have
a concept of
the noises that they're making
when they're trying to communicate with
each other and the slamming and the
steps so you think
i automatically perceived that something
else was going on and then when you
understand what's going on oh like oh
okay they're just trying to communicate
with each other
they're expressing themselves falling
apart as a team
um but i also thought i felt like the
sequences where they talk about how they
they play both hearing and deaf football
teams
and
uh that sequence at the end where
they're playing that hearing
football team for their homecoming game
and and you hear the hearing coach like
they're deaf but you're gonna have to
forget about that because they're
still can beat you
um
but then when you show because you asked
amari like how do they talk to each
other during the game and talk about
what they're going to do
they're actually better at communicating
with each other than the other football
team is i was like so no wonder
different and different
and different
you know it's different you know when
remember when they're playing a deaf
team
they got to hide their sides yes
like any team they have secret codes for
their plays right they don't even
even an nfl team they're not describing
the play they have a name for it so the
other team doesn't know
um yeah yeah their communication is
different um
it's got to be line of sight
right they have to see the person
signing so
each player really has to be pretty
present and mindful and focused
or they'll miss
what's going on they gotta catch that
quarterback has to catch the sign from
his coach and then convey it in a huddle
to the team and make sure everyone's
watching um and so
yeah it's different
have you so have you showed the film
sorry let me say one thing jenny you
would say
in terms of sound it's interesting you
know i early on i learned you know
it's not they're not they don't live in
a silent world you know that they're
actually quite loud and we wanted to
show that so
those scenes
in the locker room for instance banging
on
turning off the lights and banging on
uh the lockers and yelling um that's the
way they express themselves and it's not
like all of them are 100 death there's
levels so
off they do make noise and they do hear
things and they certainly feel things so
i would say
silence might not even be
the right word
they're yeah those rituals that they
have of of turning off the lights like
all the the dances that they have that
they all do together and
it was so much about bodies and movement
it was like a ballet it was it was so
incredible to watch
just you know contemplating bodies that
young
that are able to play football and then
go out and dance all night but the way
that they were shot was so
beautiful and entrancing
and um it's a very sensual film i think
i was
uh when i was watching i was like why
are my eyes so in love with this film
just like drinking it in and i think
that's it's as a visual
visually sensual
um thing to look at um thank you
so
what about your your trajectory um
a filmmaking wise how did you end up
with um making the oscar shortlist and
and then being on netflix
um actually netflix really made this
film with me it was like i said a 10
plus year journey and lots of stops and
starts and
the timing was right and perhaps the
time was right because
of amari's story and jalen's story and
teddy's story and lyra's story right
maybe it was this year is what connected
me more um and ultimately netflix so i
we we brought this to uh
to netflix
and they came aboard as a netflix
original before we started filming so we
very much made this with them it was
a really
supportive
amazing experience um not just in
filmmaking but
the sensitivity to accessibility even in
post
subtitles and captions and
hey if it's on service it's this if it's
shown publicly it's this and really
having a lot of discussions about that i
mean i was fortunate uh
to have a great partner in in um one of
the netflix post people i hope he
doesn't mind me calling him out stephen
johns because he's a coda which is a
child of deaf adults both of his parents
um
are deaf his dad his father actually
passed during um i think post
and so
yes he was my post guru from netflix but
also personally
being someone that's hearing but the
child of deaf adults he was really
instrumental in helping me
like on a personal level along with my
executive producer niall demarco who's a
deaf advocate
in in getting it right because this film
is
for a deaf audience as much
maybe even more so than a hearing
audience you know it's for everyone
um
the i was talking
um
to other some other shorts filmmakers
the other day about how
uh you know i spent many years i've
spent many years watching the oscars and
for
for most of those years the shorts
categories
were like when you'd get up and go get a
snack right on the on the oscars
i think mostly because people didn't
have access
to see them you know you'd watch the
ceremony and when you
would see them present that category
you'd watch the trailers for each one
and go oh my god that looks great that's
a beautiful way to see it
see you do you feel excited that people
yeah look it's it's not just shorts
yeah and i wouldn't even say it's just
shorts it's documentaries you know
they're
i've always loved documentaries that's
why i'm doing it but
there's so much more opportunity
now
um
because of platforms and outlets like
netflix
that um you're embracing documentaries i
think people also in a very complicated
world perhaps
psychologically want authenticity and
truth
um
and
you know
i don't look at it as a short film i
look at it as a film you know it's just
a different length and i don't look at
it as a
a stepchild and neither did netflix and
neither do these other platforms that i
speak to which is
perhaps this is the appropriate length
for this film but it's a film and it's
not lesser than you know and um not
saying anyone thinks that i'm just
saying you know if you go onto a
platform it's not saying this is the
short film category it's up there with
everything else and yeah it's amazing
you know um yeah there's more
accessibility to it for sure and look
if you have a little break or you want
to take a little break from work you
have time to watch a short film during
the day you don't have to wait till
night time
right so very shareable
do you think that um
this form the short form you'll continue
doing work in in this format or do you
have any plans to continue
um making shorts
yeah i look i've um
[Music]
i'm directing my fourth feature doc
right now
but i've done shorts and i'll do another
one it's i direct commercials and
branded content it's i do doc series
it's whatever is appropriate for that
story
um
is what i do and to me it's all
storytelling you know
if it's a 30-second branded content
piece if it's a series if it's
scripted or unscripted it still needs
the tenants of great storytelling you
know character
um what's it about what are you really
trying to say what do you want people to
walk away with and feel
um
[Music]
a narrative arc an emotional arc tension
and conflict goals
doesn't matter the length it's it's a
story
um so absolutely i'd do a short tomorrow
do a
teacher the next day and then do another
short you know whatever
pulls me
well thank you so much for joining me
today
this film's incredible
i'm sure that i'm going to watch it
again
um
it's been fun to talk with you about it
and
thank you jenna
uh
hey film independence been a part of my
life since i was a
production assistant
oh yeah york
back in the day yeah you know it's like
it's a sort of a
destination whether it's even
even early days of internet just just
screenings and q and a's and
you know i didn't go to film school so
in a way
places like
film independent
were and still are in my film school and
a way to connect with other filmmakers
especially in a time like today you know
where we're stuck in our homes so thanks
great to be here thank you thank you
well um
take care and um good luck
on the oscars thank you so much jen
appreciate it
[Music]
you